you know the worst kind of people
nowadays that think that they matter
more than they actually matter hands
down
people that work out and won't shut the
[ __ ] up about it I cannot stand this
[ __ ] bang bang bang bang bang click
click reload bang bang bang can't stand
it work out go home you don't matter
that much okay
all this inspirational culture that's
going out around this fits po lifestyle
that they're trying to convince you of
who the [ __ ] are you inspiring that's
what I want to know right
these doers would be like you know what
are used to weigh 90 pounds but now
through hard work determination
perseverance never backing down not
stopping remaining focus never veering
off track
not looking over my shoulder never dying
no no days off now I got bigger muscles
okay you know what e dicks okay
[Applause]